[Musique]
generation était l'une des têtes
d'affiché pour cette deuxième édition la
tournée les boîtes à renouveler ses dix
heures de concert cette année le groupe
ont répondu présent c'est une volonté
l'association de pouvoir montrer tout ce
qu'on a
voilà comme groupes locaux localement
dans les styles mais également des fêtes
affiche voilà la scène indépendante
française
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir faire la
fête un peu un saint quentin en yvelines
d'avoir un événement fédérateur et
citoyens voilà c'est ça qu'on essaie de
défendre nos jours
[Musique]
de la musique sur deux scènes plus de
700 spectateurs ont fait le déplacement
ganic et alberto récemment arrivé dans
le département sont venus aux curieux
non parce que je ne savais pas du tout à
quoi m'attendre et je suis arrivé enfin
ça fait plaisir que des événements comme
ça qu'ils se posent moi je viens passer
de l'espagne bien arriver sous peu
c'est une bonne ambiance je te retrouver
des amis et c'est une ville juive qui
habite maintenant à côté je travaille
comme ingénieur et je trouve que c'est
nécessaire on veut faire plus
une soirée qui a pris fin à deux heures
du matin les équipes de mets ta sauce
plonge déjà sur une troisième édition
[Musique]